[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis ein schirm guten abend
und herzlich willkommen der sport der
kommt von norbert lehmann
und auch hier auf schauen wir heute
sorge vor angriff auf kiew selensky
droht moskau mit entschlossene reaktion
die us botschaft ruft landsleute auf die
ukraine zu verlassen
energie abkommen mit kanada kannst stolz
und deutsche konzerne schmieden bündnis
für die produktion von batterien und
grünem wasserstoff
und durchwachsene erntebilanz
deutschlands bauern beklagen geringere
erträge bei getreide durch hitze und
trockenheit
vor dem ukrainischen unabhängigkeitstag
morgen wächst die sorge vor verstärkten
russischen angriffen vor allem die
hauptstadt kiew könnte ins visier
genommen werden vor einem halben jahr
hat russland seinen krieg gegen die
ukraine gestartet anfangs versuchten die
russischen truppen kiew einzunehmen die
menschen in der ukraine leisteten
erbitterten widerstand und zwang die
angreifer zum rückzug
seitdem konzentrieren sich die kämpfe
auf den osten und süden des landes aber
seit einiger zeit vermelden beide seiten
kaum noch geländegewinne alexandra
vacano über die aktuelle lage
ein tag voller politischer symbole am
morgen blau gelb die farben der ukraine
gehisst es ist der tag der
nationalflagge vor dem
unabhängigkeitstag morgen nächster
termin mit politischen signal polens
präsident in kiew verspricht so sagt er
unseren brüdern in der ukraine weitere
hilfen zu und solidarität wie auch die
vielen anderen beim online gipfel mit
mehr als 50 staaten aus europa asien
amerika afrika organisiert von der
ukraine thema die von russland
annektierte krim
um den terror zu stoppen ist es
notwendig einen sieg im kampf gegen die
russische aggression zu erringen es ist
notwendig die krim zu befreien
unterstützung auch von deutscher seite
wir machen noch einmal deutlich dass die
internationale gemeinschaft russlands
illegale imperialistische annexion
ukrainischen territorium niemals
akzeptieren wird deutschland steht fest
an der seite der ukraine so lange die
ukraine unsere unterstützung braucht
fast sechs monate krieg zehntausende
tote millionen die aus ihrer heimat
fliegen gräueltaten die welt des zeuge
bei russlands sogenannter
spezialoperationen dass wir von
russischer seite gesehen haben ist dass
man eigentlich in einen wesentlichen
kriegs zielen die man ja versucht hat
kurzfristig zu erreichen gescheitert ist
also sowohl die einnahme kias als auch
ein regime change und das einzige was
man eigentlich verbuchen kann ist die
eroberung große teile der ost ukraine
und heute wohl wieder im süden beschuss
am akw in sabaudia beide seiten werfen
sich vor das gebiet zu beschießen und
aus den usa kommen warnungen vor
russischen angriffen in der ukraine die
lage in der hauptstadt kiew angespannt
kurz vor dem nationalfeiertag morgen
auf kiew werden also angriffe befürchtet
herner hebestreit ist für uns vor ort
hannah wie bereiten sich die menschen
darauf vor
also die us botschaft hat erstmal die
landsleute dazu aufgerufen die ukraine
zu verlassen und ist die us-botschaft
damit immer sehr schnell und stand jetzt
auch noch alleine die menschen hier
haben schon heute den arbeitstag im home
office verbracht werden das morgen und
übermorgen auch noch tun öffentliche
veranstaltungen wurden abgesagt eben aus
der sorge vor russischen angriffen
hoffnungszeichen könnte sein der fußball
in der ukraine geht wieder los da die
mannschaften kommt die teilweise in
kriegsgebieten legen wird hier in kiew
gespielt im stadion ein spiel nach dem
anderen ohne zuschauer das wird alles
live im internet gestreamt der präsident
des fußballverbandes hat uns gesagt er
hofft dass wenigstens das endspiel
wieder im vollen haus stattfinden kann
wir hoffen mit den menschen in der
ukraine das ist hier heute nacht ruhig
bleibt und damit zurück zu dir ja na
danke nach kiew einer hebestreit und
deutschland wird seine waffenlieferungen
an die ukraine deutlich aufstocken in
einem umfang von mehr als 500 millionen
euro kündigt der kanzler scholz in
kanada an es geht um weitere
luftabwehrsysteme ein dutzend
bergepanzer 20 raketenwerfer
präzisionsmunition und anti drohnen
geräte den ausgaben muss der
haushaltsausschuss des bundestages noch
zustimmen und zusammen mit kanada will
bundeskanzler scholz so wörtlich
technologische und wissenschaftliche
geschichte schreiben am abend
unterzeichnen er und der kanadische
premierminister trikot ein wasserstoff
abkommen ein energieträger auf den vor
allem die deutsche stahlindustrie wartet
gewonnen wird wasserstoff wie der name
sagt aus wasser das wird gespalten in
wasserstoff und sauerstoff und zwar mit
hilfe von strom in großen mengen kommt
der aus erneuerbaren energien wie zb
windkraft spricht man von grünem
wasserstoff und auch als lieferant von
rohstoffen wie mineralien und metallen
soll kanada ein enger partner werden
details hat klaus brodbeck
dem der applaus gilt es zunächst fast
nicht zu sehen doch schnell arbeitet
olaf scholz daran dem publikum die
gegenseitige bedeutung deutschlands und
kanadas aufzuzeigen der kanzler umwirbt
die gastgeber die outlook for des new
can do pará der ausblick für unsere neue
partnerschaft könnte nicht idealer sein
wie in einem puzzle deutschland und
kanada passen perfekt als teile
zueinander
auch kann er das primitive lobt vor
allem die vielen aus deutschland
mitgereisten unternehmensvertreter
das zeigt wie ernst auch die deutsche
wirtschaft die möglichkeit nimmt die
schon bestehenden handels aber auch
partnerschaftlichen beziehungen zu
vertiefen
verträge werden unterzeichnet von
volkswagen und mercedes-benz etwa für
gemeinsame batterie produktionen
lithium im prinzip alle batterie
rohstoffe die man auch kobalt auch
explorations kompetenz und auch die
fähigkeit dieser durch stoffe zu
veredeln es geht um energie und um
rohstoffe der zukunft und um mehr
unabhängigkeit für beide länder
ein ganz wichtiges thema sind mineralien
sind ausgangsstoffe
die wir heute ehrlicherweise zum großen
teil aus china beziehen die canaria zur
verfügung haben obwohl wir gemeinsam
überlegen wie wir die besser explodieren
können es ist ein erster schritt das ist
wichtig und das ist ein erster kleiner
schritt aber alles hat einen anfang
strahlend sonne und minen vor der
skyline von toronto womöglich ein guter
anfang
während robert habeck mit in kanada ist
wächst die kritik an der gasanlage
design wirtschaftsministerium
ausgearbeitet hat denn seitdem bekannt
wurde dass zwölf unternehmen insgesamt
34 milliarden euro aus der gasanlage
haben wollen wird diskutiert ob
überhaupt alle staatliche hilfe
benötigen müssen die kriterien dafür
also nachgeschärft werden über die
debatte kam frischer das ziel der gas
umlage ist klar wichtige
energieversorger vor drohender insolvenz
retten und die kosten dafür auf viele
schultern verteilen doch über die
aktuelle regelung gibt es in der ampel
streit denn es könnten auch unternehmen
profitieren die das geld gar nicht
brauchen die rechtsverordnung zur gas
anlage die auf dem tisch liegt erfüllt
nicht das was robert habeck in der
vergangenen woche versprochen hat sein
versprechen wahr nur insolvenz bedrohte
unternehmen müssen gerettet werden über
die gasanlage damit der energiemarkt
nicht zusammenbricht jetzt kommt raus es
bewerben sich auch unternehmen die fette
gewinne einfahren und dividenden
ausschütten zwölf unternehmen haben
bisher ansprüche angemeldet höhe 34
milliarden euro ein großteil entfällt
auf die tatsächlich insolvenzgefährdeten
juniper und sf die ehemalige gazprom
germania weitere gasversorger wollen
aber auch hilfen sowie der schweizer
konzern axpo obwohl der seine umsätze
zuletzt verdoppelt hat kritik an der
aktuellen verordnung selbst von
parteifreunden des grünen
wirtschaftsministers
wir haben das problem in der tat dass zb
die omv aus österreich die axpo
staatskonzern aus der schweiz auch
profitieren könnten und da brauchen wir
klarheit zum beispiel beim thema
dividenden boni aber auch über gewinne
denn die gasanlage ist ja nicht dazu da
profitable unternehmen zu retten auf
nachfrage muss gestern auch eine
sprecherin von wirtschaftsminister haar
weg zu geben die gefahr einer
unternehmenspleite gehört nicht zu den
bedingungen für geld aus der gasanlage
es müssen also verschiedene
voraussetzungen gelten eine drohende
insolvenz hielt in der tat nicht dazu so
lastet jetzt der politische druck auf
robert habeck nachzuarbeiten und dafür
zu sorgen dass nur die unternehmen von
der gas umlage profitieren die sie auch
wirklich brauchen
zum fischen an der oder dort sind die
behörden bei der suche nach den ursachen
offenbar ein gutes stück weitergekommen
in den vergangenen wochen starben in der
oder auf einer strecke von rund 500
kilometern
zehntausende fische bis hoch in den
norden nach stettin ein wichtiger grund
für die umweltkatastrophe sind die
sogenannten gold algen wohl keine
illegalen einleitungen über die
spurensuche aus brandenburg berichtet ja
meyer doch immer sammeln freiwillige am
ufer der oder tote fische 100 tonnen
müssen allein auf deutscher seite
entsorgt werden die ursache liegt in
einer massenhaften vermehrung einer
giftigen algen die sonst nur in
salzhaltigem wasser verbreitet ist so
legten sich am nachmittag experten in
der sondersitzung des umweltausschusses
des brandenburger landtages fest
es gibt keine multipel den ursachen für
irgendwas fall allein das salzwasser als
im süßwasser massen entwicklung bilden
kann hat ursächlich die salz einleitung
auch wenn es genehmigte einleitungen
sind
in dem moment wo viel wasser oder ist
wer wahrscheinlich überhaupt nichts
passiert aber das nun zum ausgerechnet
minimum zu machen dass es schon schon
mehr als fahrlässig für abgeordnete und
forscher ist die umweltkatastrophe ein
alarmsignal für einen besseren umgang
mit dem deutsch polnischen grenzfluss
wir leben in zeiten des klimawandels
hohe temperaturen gleichzeitig dürren
wenig niederschläge führt dazu dass die
oder wenig wasser führt und wenn dann
noch hohe salz frachten dazu kommt und
dann eben diese jetzt neu aufgetretene
toxische algenart dann ist das gebäude
zusammen dass regelmäßig wiederkehrend
für sterben auslösen kann fast die
hälfte des gesamten fischbestandes in
der oder wurde vernichtet es wird jahre
dauern bis sich der fluss von dieser
katastrophe erholt hat
nach vielen verhandlungsrunden und
längeren warnstreiks ist der
tarifkonflikt bei den hafen
arbeiterinnen und arbeitern an der
nordseeküste bei gelebt die 12.000
beschäftigten erhalten rückwirkend zum 1
juli zwischen 7,9 und 9,4 prozent mehr
lohn im juni nächsten jahres sollen noch
mal gut vier prozent obendrauf kommen
teilte die gewerkschaft verdi mit
hitze und trockenheit damit kämpft
zurzeit fast ganz europa es könnte die
schlimmste dürre seit 500 jahren werden
sagen fachleute der eu in deutschland
trifft es zurzeit besonders die
landwirtschaft viele böden trocknen aus
die auswirkungen auf den feldern zeigen
sich regional aber sehr unterschiedlich
wie sie hier sehen könnt tiefrot die
mitte deutschlands die pflanzen im süden
und norden aber haben den vergangenen
wochen immer mal wieder wasser
abbekommen
insgesamt fällt die erntebilanz eher mau
aus aber immerhin besser als im
vergangenen jahr torge bode
erich gussen estland wird in jülich
nordrhein-westfalen 75 hektar ackerbau
und seit mai viel zu wenig regen es sind
die herbst kulturen die ihm sorgen
machen hier rechnet erich gussen mit
ernteeinbußen von bis zu 50 prozent
regen kommt die wachsen nicht mehr
weiter ist ja klar die ganz abgestorben
sind da passiert nichts mehr und die
anderen sind aber auch schon in dem
prozess das absterben der winterweizen
ist die wichtigste getreideart für
deutsche bauern hier konnten vier
prozent mehr eingefahren werden als im
letzten jahr dennoch liegt der ertrag 8
prozent unter dem durchschnitt der jahre
2014 bis 21 die preise für den
verbraucher werden wohl steigen so der
deutsche bauernverband wir haben auf der
einen seite nämlich niedrige erträge und
auf der anderen seite eine
kostenexplosion
düngemittelpreise vervierfacht
energiekosten verdoppelt
futtermittelkosten erhöht und um
überhaupt weiter wirtschaften zu können
brauchen sie als bauern höhere preis der
klimawandel macht den landwirten spürbar
zu schaffen so der bauernverband
bäuerinnen und bauern müssten sich
künftig den wetterextremen anpassen denn
die wird es wohl immer häufiger geben
dieses muster scheint sich im zuge der
globalen temperaturerhöhung im sommer zu
wiederholen es regnet immer seltener
wenn es aber regnet legend es sehr viel
örtlich eng begrenzt in kurzer zeit die
aussichten sind für erich gussen nicht
so rosig regnen soll es in den nächsten
tagen erst einmal nicht
und auch china leidet seit wochen unter
einer dürre und hitzewelle 14 regionen
und provinzen sind von mittelschwerer
bis schwerer trockenheit betroffen so
die staatliche nachrichtenagentur spa
und die behörden greifen zu regieren
maßnahmen wie unsere korrespondentin
miriam stein berichtet
dass hier sind keine waffen diese
raketen sind gefüllt mit chemikalien und
werden in die wolken geschossen um regen
zu provozieren das chinesische
staatsfernsehen veröffentlicht diese
bilder der nutzen eher bescheiden die
botschaft wir tun etwas
bis zu 45 grad seit wochen es soll der
heißeste und trockenste sommer seit
beginn der aufzeichnungen china sein der
jangtse chinas längstem fluss zeigt die
folge
normalerweise reicht das wasser bis zum
ufer dort hinten
jetzt ist nur noch dort wasser wo
eigentlich die flussmitte sein soll
die provinz sichuan im südwesten chinas
hat deshalb noch ein weiteres problem
80 prozent des stroms ins man kommt aus
wasserkraft
das haben wir so hohe temperaturen und
dürre wie seit 60 jahren nicht mit
großen und lang anhaltenden folgen
deshalb wird strom sparen jetzt
staatlich verordnet shopping malls
dürfen nur noch für wenige stunden am
tag öffnen in fabriken ist der
stromverbrauch gedeckelt bänder stehen
still das könnte auch auswirkungen auf
lieferketten haben die sowieso unter den
immer noch strengen corona maßnahmen
leiden ohne klimaanlage ist es in
manchen wohnungen so heißt es die leute
lieber im parkhaus schlafen
draußen ist es wie in einer sauna sobald
du raus gehst bist du bis auf die haut
durchnässt
wassermangel ist auch ein problem für
die landwirtschaft
diese bilder lassen erahnen was in den
kommenden jahren aus china zukommt wenn
hitzewellen wie befürchtet häufiger und
noch stärker verlaufen sollen
jetzt haben wir auf den englischen
fussball norbert läuft es ja für
jugendclub und fc liverpool alles andere
als für das ganze wohl sagen nur zwei
punkte aus drei spielen nach der
niederlage gestern abend gegen den erz
rivalen manchester united sind die reds
auf tabellenplatz 16 abgestürzt prestige
sieg für manunited klassischer fehlstart
für liverpool jürgen klopp beim
ebenfalls enttäuschend in die saison
gestarteten rivalen manchester united
der dominierte lange in der fünften
minute zehn minuten später spielt der
schwede zurück zu chatten sancho der
ehemalige dortmunder abgeklärt zum 100
dennoch gleicht klopps
ersatzgeschwächtes team vor der pause
fast aus nach kopfball milner verhindert
martina ist gerade so ein eigentor von
fern an nach dem wechsel bereitet erneut
gelang davor und diesmal vollendet
bradford
manchester united liverpool danach auch
ohne neu bayer manet und drei verletzte
mit chancen doch nur noch mühsam gelingt
ein treffer zum 2 2 1 eric den haag
erfreut kollege klopp frustriert bereits
sieben punkte rückstand zur spitze
morgen startet wieder die
deutschlandtour 120 radprofis gehen in
weimar an den start zum auftakt erstmals
ein kurzes einzelzeitfahren und dann
folgen vier etappen durch thüringen
hessen und baden württemberg das große
finale dann am sonntag in stuttgart am
vormittag vor den toren weimars
deutschlands top team bohrer hansgrohe
verpasst sich den letzten schliff vor
dem morgigen start für vorjahressieger
nils politiker im trikot des deutschen
meisters dürfte eine titelverteidigung
ausgeschlossen sein weil der
streckenprofil mit der bergankunft
samstag am schauinsland sehr
anspruchsvoll ist und er dem
teamkollegen emanuel buchmann
entgegenkommt das sollte mir echt liegen
also wenn ich gut drauf bin denke ich
schon dass ich da vorne reinfahren kann
da muss man jetzt schauen ob ich möchte
ich bei 100 prozent bin oder was mir da
infektes gekostet hat der 29-jährige
hatte die spanien-rundfahrt erkrankt
absagen müssen ein alternativprogramm
freut zumindest die radsport fans
hierzulande
das war's auch schon vom sport
dankeschön arbeit und zum schluss noch
ein blick zum könig unseres
planetensystems zum jupiter und ich
verspreche ihnen das sind bilder die
haben sie so noch nie gesehen was da am
nord- und südpol grün schimmert sind
polarlichter aufgenommen vom james webb
teleskop und der große helle weiße fleck
ist ein wirbelsturm übrigens größer als
die erde und der tobt bereits seit mehr
als 200 jahren und die letzte aufnahme
hier zeigt sogar die jupiter ringer und
zwei kleine monde vor glitzernden
galaxien
beim wetter bleibt wie es ist bis
donnerstag meist sonnig nur im osten
öfter befolgt mehr gleich von christa
haben das heute journal können sie mit
marietta slomka um 21.45 sehen was
morgen
[Musik]
guten abend der satelliten film von
heute mittag zeigt uns wie wolkenlos der
himmel unter dieser hochdruckbrücke von
skandinavien bis hin zum atlantik heute
war unterbrochen wurde dieser
hochdruckeinfluss nur von diesem kleinen
tief das hat zum einen die gewitter über
griechenland gebracht die sich der heute
mittag entwickelten und zum anderen auch
ein paar mehr wolken mit einigen
schauern in die osthälfte deutschlands
und da liegen die auch noch heute nacht
von der oder über das erzgebirge bis in
den südosten bayerns in der feuchten
luft bildet sich da auch mal nebel aber
die schauer lassen nach meist es ist
sonst klar oder gering bewölkt bei einem
milden 18 grad an der nordsee und kühlen
acht grad am alpenrand morgen früh
morgen ist es dann wieder heiß in der
westhälfte 27 bis 34 grad richtung
moseltal in der osthälfte ist es mit 24
bis 29 grad angenehmer dazu haben wir
auch hier noch die häufigeren wolken
liegen schauer gibt es aber nur
vereinzelt mal an der grenze zu
tschechien oder zu polen sonst fällt im
ganzen land leider wieder kein tropfen
regen es gibt viel sonne nachmittags
kommen dann auch noch ein paar mehr
wolken in dem westen am donnerstag haben
wir vereinzelt mal einen gewitter
nachmittags in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen ab freitag stellt sich
dann die wetterlage um es gibt mehr
schauer und gewitter tschüss